hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
i thought i'd do a video on a topic that
was requested
a while back on balanced
audio it's one of those confusing topics
uh somewhat technical and my goal in
this
video is actually to not get too
technical but uh clarify what we mean by
balanced audio and
some of the misconceptions are that are
out there
turns out there are different things
people calling balanced
there is balanced input to an audio
device
there's balanced topology inside
an audio device and there is balanced
headphone connection there are three
separate things um
let me pull up this uh topping a90 which
is a headphone amplifier because it has
two out of three in here that we could
talk about
um if you look in here there are two
sets of uh connectors on on this um
headphone amplifier we have the
traditional rca connections that
we're all hopefully are familiar with
but we also have a
uh xlr connections and thus you can
bring in xlr connections and these two
female connectors and then two male
connectors are passed through in this
case
if you use headphones you don't use
these but if you use
use it as a preamplifier you would so
in this case we call this balance
because
the difference between that and the rca
is that the rca uses this outside
chassis as the
reference so the signal varies relative
to this outside chassis and as i
explained
in in previous videos when you do that
the mains ground over here the safety
ground
can cause current leakage uh between two
pieces of equipment the remains powered
and they can actually travel over this
this shield or the outside pin of the
outside connection of rca
and if it's loud enough it'll cause the
classic hum and buzz that that you hear
when you have what is called a ground
loop the xlr connections on the other
hand
don't use the chassis as a reference
they use two wires
and those two wires um
provide a signal and therefore no matter
what is happening between you know as
far as
you know current flow between the
equipment or voltage differential
between the
two pieces of equipment as safety ground
and it won't make a difference to your
signal so it provides great immunity to
hum and buzz
a lot of people talk about oh you only
need these uh
connections if you've got a studio or
long connections and consumers never
have long connections so you don't need
this
um that's not the reason i like to
recommend them i like to recommend them
because
they completely eliminate this issue
with with ground loops
in uh i shouldn't say completely 99
of time it'll eliminate the issue with
ground loops
and in the old days we didn't have much
of a problem with with ground loops you
know we had them occasionally but not
all the time
today we have it for two reasons one is
that when we use pcs
then we wind up with this long chain of
of ground that goes through a usb cable
for example to a dac then to this one
and there's so many different voltage
differentials that you can get in ground
loops and once you get
hit with the ground loop boy i tell you
is pain and neck to solve it after the
fact
so if you've got a device that doesn't
have balanced input
your options are very limited in solving
your problem but if you start with
balanced turns out you you basically
you know have you know insurance policy
against ground loop so
even though your connection may be very
short even a few inches
i highly recommend if you can afford it
these devices tend to be more expensive
and have
balanced interconnects because of
connectors and the circuitry inside
the circuits inside and uh but if you
can
you know get the balanced version of
everything i think get balance tax now
for 150
versus unbalanced or a hundred dollars
so for extra fifty dollars on the dac
you have both outputs and you can choose
as you need it um these black balance
signals uh they're called balance
because the two
inputs that uh the two pins that bring
the signal
usually put on twisted pair wire and
come in and
therefore because the the amplifier in
there would only amplify the difference
between these two
is very immune to what we call common
mode noise so if
you know radiations or interference or
something hit these two wires as long as
the uh
signal the interference couples to both
of the pins
equally it gets filtered out it only
cares about what's different
between these two pins um so as a
convention
the driving mechanism for uh
uh for a balanced signal is also what is
called differential
meaning that these two pins they don't
swing between zero and positive
but they also swing negative to zero and
then positive so
and that usually means that you get
double the voltage
uh on a balanced interconnect versus
unbalance so
traditionally on a desktop product a dac
that only has rca output puts out only
two volts
but if you use xlr it gives you four
volts and
that can be an advantage also as far as
you know if you have longer
lengths or you know you can also get
better dynamic range on this thing
so but just know that
at high level balanced is a good thing
to
guard against
into ground loops and if you have the
option
it's a good thing to use now some people
then talk about okay
is the circuitry inside that's also
balanced or you know differential inside
my advice to you is not to get wrapped
around the axle on that one at all
why do we care that the benefit of
balance as i mentioned it comes in
over the wiring and external world
internally whether it has a benefit or
not
is up to the designer to choose it does
make things more expensive
uh it makes it insanely more expensive
with things like tube amplifiers
um and uh in general to me it's
basically none of my business if it's
balanced or not a lot of people complain
so internal it is not balanced therefore
it doesn't matter no it absolutely does
because
these receivers are balanced and that's
all you want to avoid ground loop
whether the circuits are inside a
balance or not we're going to measure it
and the measurements will tell us if
they got better fidelity
they didn't get better fidelity i don't
care if they use balance or not i don't
vice versa if the fidelity is superb
what do i care about the internal
topology of this thing it's like
worrying about what the nuts and bolts
are inside your engine you know you care
about the horsepower and performance
okay so those are the inputs on this
thing and these inputs
are available on preamplifiers power
amplifiers
in this case headphone amplifiers audio
interfaces professional interfaces
so remember this is an input benefit so
just
you know from point of view keeping it
separate from other things i'm going to
talk about
so inputs are in here balanced you want
balance if you can get them
what's inside you don't care now in case
of headphone amplifiers the industries
really screwed things up in that they
went out and invented so in here we have
a quarter inch
jack which is the classic
headphone jack that you would have has
got three pins on it
now a headphone actually has two cups in
it plus two little speakers in it
so each one of these has two wires so
total is four wires
how did you get three wires well they
take the negatives of the two drivers
and time together to save on wiring and
the pins on this
and the two positives is what the other
two pins are so
you want that with three pins if you
have that this is called
unbalanced or traditional output then it
comes in both
quarter inch and three and a half
millimeter uh
versions that you know on portable
device and and
uh there's a mishmash out there of what
headphones have what and so you wind up
having adapters and
all this stuff so from convenience point
of view
look at what you're buying as far as
headphones and and uh
and amplifiers and this side but this is
the standard
imp uh three pin up whenever you see
three pin
is what you call unbalanced now
some people start inventing the notion
of a balanced
connection and i'll show you an example
of that on this
drop ether cx headphone
and you can see it's a it's a form of a
sort of xlr type of connector
so very robust and that's good um
it it comes with four pins however not
three
what have they done they simply brought
out the two pins from each side
independently they did not join the
negatives together
what that means is that you can drive
both cups independent of each other
importantly because the negatives are no
longer attached together
you can use differential signaling
to pump twice as much voltage over this
than you can with the three pin so
instead of zero to two volts you can go
from minus two to plus two
so you have four volts differential
let's say instead of two volts
power is equal to voltage square times
divided by the impedance so if you
double the voltage you can actually get
quadruple the power
okay so in theory you could
transmit more power if you're not
limited by the three pin connection that
in the older ones by decoupling the two
channels
independently now that is called
differential signaling or differential
drive it has nothing to do with the word
balanced
whoever coined that term the first time
didn't understand what balance means
headphones by definition are always
balanced they're two pins for each one
of these
and they're floating in air they're not
connected to the chassis they're not
connected to ground
so there never was an unbalanced
connection so even the older ones
were never unbalanced it just said they
had one common pin so you couldn't drive
them differentially
if all this too complicated don't worry
it nets out to the fact that
if you have a balanced connection and i
have an amplifier
headphone amplifier oops headphone
amplifier that has the mating connection
in here
the amplifier can choose to send twice
as much power
into twice much voltage really into the
headphone
as it can with quarter inch output now
you should know that
some headphone amplifiers small
percentage of them
have these kinds of connectors for
convenience only they will put out the
same voltage that they do on their
quarter edge
no difference in this case i'll show you
the measurements in a second it actually
is producing more voltage in here but
just know that
you can't automatically assume that if
you see xlr connection
on this thing or balance connection as
it's called that
you have double the voltage available
now some people
originally thought the benefit of that
output was that
by separating the negatives in the two
cups
that you get better crosstalk the better
separation
between the two cups it's a total total
non-issue
we don't need a ton of crosstalk to get
channel separation
um in in
two cups three wires already plenty good
we don't need the
separation i've never seen anybody prove
that you actually do get
better separation i plan on testing that
at some point but
for now it it really get that out of
your vocabulary that
that you get better channel separation
and better crosstalk it's just
not an important thing at all the
benefit
if it exists means more power or
convenience
now many headphones can be converted to
balance if they come unbalanced if they
have a removable
wire cable and in this case
you're sort of stuck in this aka k371
because it only has one wire
so you can unless this is four pin which
i don't remember if it is
you can't modify this but some other
headphones you can actually
like this one you can see that you can
disconnect these and get aftermarket
cables
unfortunately for whatever reason you
get gouged to death
when you get balanced cables they can be
40 60 80 100
for those cables and when they come with
specialized connectors
usually you can't sometimes you can't
make your own either
um so it's a bit of an annoyance it's a
complete mess
it's more of a mess than even i talked
about because
it's not just xlr but they come in
multiple
connectors this is a 4.4 millimeter
and it's actually also balanced uh again
typically is balanced
it also comes in two and a half
millimeter very skinny
skinnier than three and a half
millimeter uh it's even skinnier than
this
uh which is suitable for portable
devices although very fragile
uh connector and uh
that also provides you know for balanced
uh
output if if the uh amplifier can
produce
so with that why don't we switch to a a
a review of of this product so maybe you
can see the pictures better than uh
that i was showing you here so again
this is the device in here the
excuse me topping a90 you see the four
pin
xlr um differential output
although everybody calls it balance and
i've started calling it balance because
i got tired
of just calling it differential and
people wouldn't know what i'm talking
about
so you can see the word balance written
over here so
both of these are balanced outputs and
then you have it's a single lender osce
as a traditional quarter inch and if you
have 3.5 millimeter then you need one of
these adapters
to go from three and a half to a quarter
of an inch
and this is the back as i mentioned
these are the input side xlrs which have
nothing to do with the output side
you could have rca inputs over here and
have balanced output
for headphones there is no nothing tying
these two together
each one of them you have to look at
independently whether you have that or
don't have it
so this one is a state-of-the-art uh
device that's why i use it for all my
headphone testing it has tremendous
amount of power
uh its distortion is less than 140 db
which is
like 25 db below threshold of hearing
just incredibly good
i'm not going to get into the how good
it is but you could read the review
you see his noise floor is just amazing
it's instrument class
noise 4. better than 21 bits
it's just it's hard to get anything
better than 21 and
and we have it here uh it ranked at the
time i was testing and i think it's
still so
it as far as noise floor is so low that
even if you use a sensitive iem
it still uh you know has basically that
silent background and it's
it's the best i've measured but the
reason i wanted to bring you here was
to look at balance versus unbalance so
if you look at 33 ohm load it puts out
two watts of power
using its quarter inch unbalanced output
but when i switched to the uh
balanced output the impedance changed to
50 ohm
so the number is not going to be four to
one but but notice that it actually
produces almost five watts of power
why big because again in a differential
output mode for a headphone
is able to use plus or minus swings so
you double the voltage and therefore
it can potentially get quadruple amount
of power and
that's what you see in here now do you
need this
you may not um if you look at the
headphone measurements i do
and i can quickly go up here and
show you a focal utopia that i just
reviewed if you go in here i produce
this graph in here it tells you how
inefficient or efficient your headphone
is
case of this for cal utopia is extreme
extremely it's very efficient so
for this one you don't need balanced
output is plenty
loud but if you have this high five
manage e6 or
you know the bear dynamic dt 990
um these are bits headphones this
head headphone these things most
definitely
require balanced input to pump out
enough voltage now
there are some crazy output single-ended
uh
headphones topping actually has one i
forget the model number that they
recently released
and it puts a tremendous amount of power
using single ended if that's the case
then you don't need balanced output
remember that's all that is used for
when it comes to headphone amplifiers
it's just more power
if you don't need it because your
headphones already efficient or
because the single-ended output is just
so powerful anyway
like in this case i'm getting uh
you know over 2 watts at 33 ohms
on about 0.2 watts 300 ohm um
if you don't need it more than this then
great you already have what you want so
it doesn't mean that you should rush out
and get something with balance output
a lot of people say can should i upgrade
the balance i'm like is your iphone loud
enough and like yeah i guess pretty
pretty loud if it's not if it's getting
loud and it's not getting distorted
you're all set now from longevity point
of view
if you got the money go buy a headphone
amplifier that is like this basically
yeah balance input so you know you have
noise immunity
for ground loops and you have balance
output which means that any kind of
headphone you buy
is going to be efficient enough so
because you never know if you're
operating down here and all of a sudden
you really review of a headphone you
jump at it and buy it and bring it home
and
connect it and all of a sudden it's like
oh i gotta crank it all the way to the
max
and when i do that it's getting
distorted or just doesn't get loud
enough
then you know you're sort of stuck so
best of all worlds
is balanced input balance output but you
know this will cost you unfortunately so
let's look at what the a90 cost
500 now these prices have gone up
because of covid and
shipping restrictions between
us and and uh asia um
and so hopefully over time you know your
two will see these go back down a little
bit
but for now yeah it does cost money
on portable devices and phones and
otherwise uh
this when you get to 300 ohms with a
high impedance load
voltage is everything to increase this
number you need voltage
and current is not that important and
differential output
like i said it doubles this voltage so
it's very much
needed on many devices that are anemic
otherwise
i've tested little dongles that oh most
angles
most phones only put on one volt good
dongles put out two volts
but the ones that do balance actually
put out four volts
so again that enables them to have four
times the power
of the voltage and in theory four times
the power
coming out of them so it's a good thing
to have
um you know if you got power hungry
headphones if you have efficient
headphones
and forever you're going to stick with
them then single ended
is fine so remember to summarize there's
two different
concepts in here we have inputs and
excuse me which is only needed for noise
immunity and then the output is needed
for
power and then sometimes with just
compatibility because your headphone
vendor
assume that you know they're going to
ship you balanced ones and
if you don't have that you can get
adapters by the way they're 20 30
dollars i've got the adapters from
everything to everything
because you're going to need it so you
can take a balanced headphone by the way
plug in an adapter or go unbalanced and
connect to this so don't worry if your
headphone comes balanced
excuse me with balance you could just
short out the two pins the two negatives
and get three pins out of it
the inverse you can't do with an adapter
you have to get all new chords
because the wires already shorted out at
the beginning
and you can't separate them back out
okay so hopefully you found this useful
and practical i know it's a little bit
theoretical but uh
you know if you're into headphones and
everything you need to know this and if
you're into uh
audio in general i recommend that you do
look at getting balanced uh
inputs and outputs on your devices if
you can
okay thanks for watching and see you in
a future video bye-bye